how's it going everyone it's lauren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything mcu and we are finally in
2021 the year that spider-man 3
in the marvel cinematic universe is
going to come out now of course marvel
has
a ton of different projects coming out
in 2021 including one division in just
10 days but right now there are still so
many unanswered questions about
spider-man 3.
sony promised us a first look at
spider-man 3 before the end of 2020
that didn't happen no surprise there
2020 sucked all around but we still
don't have an official title for it and
marvel studios and sony haven't even
come out and mentioned
toby maguire and andrew garfield yet to
officially confirm them
so what's the deal well today we have a
new report that may offer a little bit
of clarity concerning the situation
and it also mentions that andrew and
toby could be filming spider-man 3
right now which means leaks could be
coming very very
soon i'll break it all down but if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news and spider-man 3 news
so it's been reported before and has
been reported for a few months now that
toby maguire is going to be in
spider-man 3 and he's going to be in
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
this report comes from some pretty
credible sources such as
daniel richman and he recently reported
over the past couple of weeks that
sony and marvel studios want to make
sure toby mcguire's contract
is locked down and signed before they
officially announce anything he has
committed to the film they are just
working out some final details and today
we have a report that further goes into
this coming from a writer from
discussing film
another credible media outlet and
according to what this writer said on
twitter
andrew garfield and toby mcguire are
filming right now
now if you recall a couple of weeks ago
toby mcguire was spotted in la going to
a costume fitting
this came right around the time that
spider-man 3 began filming so the timing
lines up perfectly
now a couple of weeks went by the
holidays are over and it's time to get
back to work
shooting spider-man 3 which means toby
maguire since he was just fitted for a
costume is probably filming at this
point
and as far as we've heard from multiple
sources andrew garfield
is signed on to reprise his role as
spider-man in spider-man 3 so he's good
to go which means he is most likely
filming as well which this report states
andrew and toby are filming right now
now if this is the case
this is absolutely incredible news for a
few different reasons
one is that if they're filming there
will most likely be leaks very soon it
happens with every single movie or tv
show we get leaked photos we get leaked
videos especially when they have to film
outside and we've already gotten leaked
photos and videos of tom holland and
zendaya for spider-man 3. so we should
be seeing tom and andrew pretty soon
but another great thing and a second
part to this report is that toby mcguire
took
longer than expected to sign which is
why marvel and sony haven't announced
anything yet
this report also lines up with daniel
richmond's previous report that stated
the same thing
but if toby is filming now that means
that they've most likely signed the
contract
you typically don't start filming until
the contract is done and if that's what
they were waiting for to give us our
first look to give us a little teaser to
give us the official title
and to just announce the spider-verse
that means they can now
if they were waiting for that to be done
it's now done which means they can make
their official announcement
now going back to a few months ago a
sony executive did 100
promise we would get a first look at
spider-man 3 by the end of 2020.
we didn't get that but we can presume
according to these recent reports that
the reason we didn't get it is because
toby wasn't officially on board yet
if he is now in theory we should be
getting some announcement from them
some type of teaser or the title
relatively soon if they were going to
try and get it to us by the end of 2020
that means they're ready to go and
announce it right now
they're just waiting for a few things to
line up which it does seem like has
happened
so although we don't have an official
date or time frame this new report today
stating that toby is filming
is great news and means that our first
look at spider-man 3
is coming very soon and hopefully like i
said we get some leaked photos and
videos soon officially seeing toby
mcguire and
andrew garfield and spider-man suits
once again
so be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of my spider-man update
videos
don't forget to like the video and leave
a comment down below letting me know how
excited you are for spider-man 3.
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof